Amazon's journey to the Dark Tower is
over Amazon Studios has opted to pass on
as planned adaptation of Stephen King's
eighth novel opus after reportedly being
dissatisfied with the pilot this come to
little more than two years after the
feature film starring giedrius Alba and
a Matthew McConaughey the streamer will
shop it's two completed scripts to other
Studios according to Deadline the news
comes as a bit of a shock King fans were
sight for The Dark Tower to receive the
serial treatment which would have been a
great fit for the extremely dense and
profoundly weird material the novel
series deals of Roland the last of a
long line of near-mythical gunslingers
and his quest to ascend the titular
tower which is a nexus of all possible
realities he's opposed by the mysterious
man in black as well as a Crimson King
an evil extra-dimensional entity who has
featured directly or indirectly in
several of King's works well Amazon has
made no official announcements regarding
the series cast and crew it's been
widely reported that the series
showrunner was Glen Mazzara who had
worked on The Walking Dead and the
shield some strike and yaz / / Conan
have been cast as Roland and the man in
black respectively and guardians of the
galaxy's Michael Rooker and Jerome Flynn
from Game of Thrones had also joined the
series in undisclosed roles
unfortunately unless the series has
picked up by another network called
streamer Meszaros dark tower will never
see the light of day fans who are
disappointed by the 2017 feature film
which attempted to cram several novels
worth of story into one film and well
failed now has something else to be
disappointed about Amazon has made no
public statements about why the plug was
poured in the series but deadline
sources indicate that it wasn't just one
thing of course as one might have
predicted it was reported that mazarron
company were having a tough time
wrangling the material what works on the
page doesn't always work on the screen
and The Dark Tower novels serve as an
absolutely splendid illustration of this
truth some of the imagery would be near
impossible to depict and some of its if
we're being honest would look incredibly
silly no matter how it was depicted
aside from these troubles however it was
also reported that Amazon's browser
simply didn't feel that the pilot was up
to
and that's it would have suffered by
comparison with other fantasy properties
the streamer has cooking such as Lord of
the Rings and the Wheel of Time well
that's certainly a bummer for fans there
was a silver lining here as the 2017
film proved that Dark Tower is an
extremely easy property to botch and we
submit that it's totally possible the
powers that be at Amazon have actually
saved us from another half-baked
adaptation who knows as to whether any
other brave souls will pick up the dark
tower torch it's tough to say it's also
possible that motherís series will be
rescued by Netflix or HBO but it seems
more likely that whatever problems
Amazon have with the pilots won't be
overlooked by other potentially
interested parties if indeed some
intrepid creator decides to start from
scratch on a fresh adaptation they would
do well to heed the advice of Ron Howard
who produce a feature film and also
oversaw a planned Italian TV series
which never materialized speaking with
Collider last year howard indicated that
if he had to do it over again he would
have leaned into the weirdness of the
source material rather than trying to
shoehorn it into a mainstream friendly
package he told the outlets but he
always felt like we were kind of holding
back something sometimes this happens on
these projects where everybody's best
intentions you're all pulling in a
direction and then you sort of say was
that the right direction and that
wouldn't say the movie was all
compromised I do think it was just a
sense of maybe too much listening to
what you think that the marketplace is
calling for instead of the essence of
what Stephen King was giving us
hopefully one day we'll get the
mind-blowing serial adaptation that The
Dark Tower deserves but it likely won't
come from Amazon check out one of our
newest videos right here plus even more
looper videos but your favorite movies
and TV shows are coming soon subscribe
to our YouTube channel and to the bail
so you don't miss a single one
[Music]